je suis endormi
Antonova d'automne
allié
J'appellerais que ton père est très
mauvais et ça revient à 20 ici
c'était re maria aujourd'hui samedi dimanche et
lundi le lundi quand ton père
entrer dans la rémunération extraordinaire qui
nous donnons une partie en ce moment nous ne les facturons pas
la tête et de cela ils ne peuvent pas rester
personne
jusqu'à ce que nous allons passer d'une opportunité à
la grosse [ __ ]
les gens qui nous ont tués meurent
la mort jamais
entendu certains des chats
Tous les jours je rends l'eau folle
marcher
ça fait un an pour les gemini parce que le
[ __ ] c'est mauvais pour moi je ne mens jamais
quand je dis une chose ça devient
vrai et moi
mon père ma mémoire no 76
Oui